known for their innovation and ingenuity
the afghan girls robotics team has
competed around the globe on projects
including building a ventilator with car
parts
our fabric port is about solving the
communities and our community problem
and i'm so interested to in the future
to serve my people and help my people
they had left kabul days before it was
taken by the taliban
speaking from doha they say they hope to
return
it's
normal that everyone out here but
i hope that and they can continue and i
want it from the new government that let
the our new generation lead the girls
and boys to continue their education
although articulate about what they want
for the future
as the country transitions and the
future is uncertain
it can be
overwhelming the team leader tells me
it's untenable to coordinate getting all
girls who want an education out of
afghanistan
instead she wants to engage with the
taliban
and for both sides to build trust
we have to making sure that our younger
generation have access to the tools and
guidance to making a better afghanistan
to become the next scientist
entrepreneur and technologist
this is what we needed for afghanistan
and this is what our wish for
afghanistan the afghan girls robotics
team said they hope to continue their
education here in qatar foundation their
future is in afghanistan they hope that
life under taliban rule is different
from the 1990s and they want to continue
to compete around the world
the taliban has promised they would
respect women's rights within the norms
of islamic law a spokesman's twitter
page shows girls going back to school
but despite the assurances some afghans
see the taliban's gains as dangerous for
women
the former captain of the afghan women's
football team khalid popal herself a
refugee
has been helping to get her former team
out of kabul
since this fall of kabul
it had things have become very hopeless
for people there
and
especially women and girls are very
scared and afraid of their future
some fear that progress will be in peril
others are pinning their hopes on reform
and to work towards a positive future
for women and girls
laura about a manly al jazeera doha